Oxford est l'une des plus vieilles
universités du monde président Nobel ou
champion olympique tous les grands noms
ils sont passés sur la centaine
d'étudiants célèbres on retrouve
Oscar Wilde Tolkien Stephen Hawking et
plus de 30 premiers ministres
britanniques sur le CV ça claque 90%
trouve direct un job prestigieux mais
qu'est-ce qui se cache derrière ces
usines à célébrités comment y accédons
qu'est-ce qu'on y apprend découvrons
ensemble les secrets des écoles
université d'élite quelle est la
meilleure université du monde sans
surprise tous les classements sont
dominés par des américains et
britanniques pas étonnant on y parle
anglais la langue des publications
scientifiques mais si elle domine c'est
surtout quels sont les plus riches
Harvard pèsent plus de 50 milliards de
dollars autant que le budget annuel
français de toutes l’éducation nationale
si vous prenez les billig le groupe des
8 plus anciennes universités américaines
on dépasse carrément le budget d'un pays
comme le Portugal ou l'Irlande les frais
d'inscription sont très élevés et elles
reçoivent de gros dons des entreprises
mais aussi des anciens élèves est-ce que
c'est non le top 10 des écoles avec le
plus d'ex étudiants devenus milliardaire
et entièrement américain tout cet argent
ça leur permet de rester au top dimanche
infrastructures les meilleurs
laboratoires et des enseignants
chercheurs les plus compétents qui
soient votre prof peut être un prix
Nobel tout ça en petit comité d'une
vingtaine d'élèves avec votre nom sur
les tables disposés de telle sorte à
maximiser les interactions à Stanford
600 élèves suivant un cours
d'informatique ils vont diviser le
groupe en 50 classes de 10 élèves pour
que chacun avance à son rythme même les
activités universitaires regardez le
campus de Cambridge ou de Yale
l’environnement d'études est idyllique
surtout que la plupart du temps vous
habitez sur place c'est ça qui fait
toute la différence ce qu'on apprend
dans ces universités n'a rien
d'exceptionnel vous trouverez la même
chose à commencer par internet où vous
avez les cours filmés les PDF en ligne
tout ce savoir à votre disposition mais
il vous manque l'environnement la
pédagogie exceptionnelle et le nom sur
le CV bien sûr car les grandes
universités ont une meilleure réputation
c'est tellement sûr d'y rentrer que
c'est un gage de qualité pour
l'employeur comptez aussi sur l'immense
réseau d'anciens élèves les alumnies qui
sont bien placés évidemment il se co-ope
entre eux entre deux CV on préférera
celui qui a fait la même école que nous
en France aussi on a aussi des
établissements réputés mais leur
fonctionnement est très différent dans
les universités américaines vous entrez
sans forcément avoir une spécialisation
vos cours c'est un tronc commun très
varié littérature ingénurie
épistémologies histoire et quelques
options plus spécifiques avec pour
objectif d'obtenir au bout de quatre ans
un Bachelor of hearts l’équivalent d'une
licence de 3 ans en Europe Harvard une
fois que vous êtes accepté vous
choisissez vous-même votre programme
parmi les 3700 cours disponibles ou vous
impose le minimum ensuite tout est à la
carte en France l'éducation des élites
passe plutôt par les grandes écoles et
c'est très spécialisé si vous entrez à
suboptique vous êtes quasi condamné à
devenir ingénieur optique et photonique
pour suivre des cours d'un autre domaine
vous devez faire une double licence avec
des plannings pas toujours adaptés et
une grosse charge de travail même sur la
charge de travail on on a deux approches
différentes en France les grandes écoles
nécessitent souvent d'avoir fait une
classe prépa donc à 18 ans sans même
savoir si vous avez été accepté dans les
écoles de vos rêves vous faites deux
fois plus d'heures de cours qu'un ancien
étudiant de Harvard par la suite ça se
calme un peu alors que dans les
universités à l'américaine le rythme
augmente avec le niveau d'études
attention ça ne veut pas dire que nos
formations sont moins bonnes elles
attirent le monde entier jusqu'à n’ont
pas le même objectif on a trois
établissements qui se distinguent à
l'échelle mondiale l'université
Paris-Saclay l'université PSL est la
Sorbonne on occupe deux places dans le
top 3 mondial en mathématiques meilleur
que nous en Europe il y a les Suisses
avec le thurique et le PFL et les écoles
asiatiques dans tout ça selon le
classement PISA qui compare les
performances des systèmes éducatifs la
Chine et le Japon sont des exemples il y
a pas mal d'opportunités la Chine
représente 22% du total de tous les
étudiants de l'OCDE forcément on y
retrouve des universités d'élite comme
thinguan extrêmement sélect pour les
étudiants chinois avec un nombre maximum
d'élèves acceptés par région d'origine
alors que les occidentaux peuvent
profiter de programmes d'échanges pour y
accéder plus facilement vous y suivez
vos cours en anglais à peine des paysans
payer ces grandes écoles ça fait mal aux
portefeuille il vous faut des finances
saines justement notre partenaire YOMANI
accompagne les jeunes dans leur
éducation financière on avait déjà
travaillé avec eux sur cette vidéo
science et vous l'avez adoré ils sont
spécialistes de l'assurance vie le
placement favori des Français au lieu de
laisser votre argent gelé dans un compte
bancaire qui perd de la valeur avec
l'inflation vous mettez un peu tous les
mois sur yumoni vous décidez de votre
niveau de risque allant de 2 à 10 si
vous voulez de l'écho responsable ou non
le tout avec les frais les plus bas du
marché le reste c'est entre les mains
d'expert et d'intelligence artificielle
qui vont faire fructifier votre argent
pas besoin de papier tout se fait en
ligne avec un chat pour répondre à vos
questions c'est un placement bien régulé
on n'est pas sur du paris sportif à
l'espérance de gain négative perso c'est
ce que j'utilise moi-même alors faites
une simulation gratuite sur yumoni.fr et
commencez à investir lia en description
comment rejoindre ces universités vous
avez fait votre choix vous voulez aller
à Harvard Stanford ou Berkeley le top du
top première des illusion vous avez beau
être le meilleur avec vos 20 sur 20 bah
en fait vous n'êtes pas du tout le
meilleur quand le taux d'acceptation ne
dépasse pas les 5 % avoir des bonnes
notes ne suffit plus il vous faut un
parcours exemplaire en dehors des cours
genre solistes dans un orchestre
capitaine d'une équipe sportive bénévole
pour des œuvres caritatives ce qu'il
cherche ce sont des profils leaders
innovateur passionnés il faut avoir le
potentiel de faire rayonner l'école en
plus de la paperasse classique sur
common Apple l'équivalent américain de
parcoursup on va vous demander tous vos
relevés de notes lettre de motivation et
recommandation de vos professeurs avec
ça la terreur des étudiants les tests
standardisés d'abord un test pour
évaluer votre niveau d'anglais mais
surtout les deux mastodont le SAT et le
Act des QCM qui traitent une grande
variété de sujets sciences maths
histoire on juge pas uniquement vos
connaissances mais aussi votre capacité
de réflexion plusieurs études ont montré
une relation entre les le résultat de ce
test et la future réussite sociale ils
sont censés être méritocratiques et
réduire les inégalités mais pour réussir
faut s'entraîner très tôt si votre
entourage peut vous aider par l'argent
ou l'expérience vous avez déjà un énorme
avantage par exemple les familles
asiatiques sont connues pour
surentraîner leur enfant alors pour
contrer ça l'université mettent des
malus sous étudiants asiatiques et des
bonus pour les Afro-Américains ou les
Hispaniques le blanc lui serait la
normalité aux États-Unis la sélection
raciale et sans tabou le but étant
d'avoir une proportion égale d'étudiants
de chaque ethnie et de chaque sexe
certains tentent même de gruger les
parents payent des fortunes pour que
leur enfant passe le test avec quelqu'un
qui leur donne les réponses en leur
inventant un faux handicap ou en
modifiant carrément les notes pas
étonnant que les élèves de s'université
viennent plus des 1% les plus riches que
des 60 les plus pauvres et ce n'est pas
dû aux frais d'inscription contrairement
à une idée reçue les universités
prestigieuses aux USA coûte souvent
moins cher que les autres alors oui une
année avoisine les 60000 dollars mais
vous n'allez pas payer autant la plupart
se base sur les revenus de vos parents
si ils gagnent moins de 75000 dollars
par an c'est gratuit en France et au
Royaume-Uni on préfère un système de
concours pour compléter le dossier c'est
tout l'enjeu des prépas dont vous parlez
mais là encore tout ne se valent pas au
lycée Sainte-Geneviève ou Henri IV c'est
20 à 30 % des élèves qui réussissent les
concours les plus difficiles quand la
moyenne nationale est à 5 en 2018 80%
des ennemis à l'École polytechnique
venez de seulement 10 lisser bien
spécifique en 2021 9% des élèves de
grandes écoles étaient de milieu
défavorisés alors qu'ils sont 20% des
étudiants à bac + 3 bac + 5 ça
s'explique d'abord par le contexte
social dans les familles les plus riches
on vous encourage souvent à faire de
grandes études si vous avez grandi à
Paris vous avez trois fois plus de
chance d'y accéder la capitale attirant
les meilleurs professeurs pas faute
d'essayer d'inverser la tendance avec
des primes pour enseignants banlieue
mais ça ne marche pas les concours eux
diffèrent beaucoup selon l'école parmi
les plus réputés il y a les concours
d'accès à l'école polytechnique aux
mines au pont et aux écoles normales
supérieures bonne chance à ceux qui
aiment les défis faire face sombre des
élites en France les écoles de commerce
sont tristesment célèbres pour leur
dérive à travers les soirées les
bizutages il y a une véritable culture
de l'humiliation soit disant pour
s'intégrer faut dire que là-bas plus
qu'ailleurs se faire des contacts et
indispensables les gens avec qui vous
étudiez les clubs que vous rejoignez
définiront votre avenir il y a un
véritable effet de groupe qui pousse à
accepter de cette situation par peur de
devenir celui ou celle qu'on ne voudra
pas embaucher le pire quand ça s'ébruite
la direction tente souvent de minimiser
l'affaire pour conserver sa réputation
c'est loin d'être un cas isolé à
Polytechnique près d'une étudiante sur 4
et victime d'une violence à caractère
sexuel à centralupelec 150 agressions
sur l’année 2020 2021 141 a
AgroParisTech dernièrement Centrale
Lille vient de se faire pointer du doigt
à cause de groupe WhatsApp ouvertement
raciste dans beaucoup d’universités
d'élite américaine vous avez plus de
risques de souffrir d'anxiété ou de
dépression de vous droguer ou de
commettre des actes de délinquance mais
pourquoi les étudiants sont-ils une
population à risque d'abord à cause de
la pression sociale il y a les parents
ils ont envie que vous réussissiez au
moins aussi bien que et après avoir
sacrifié deux années de votre vie en
classe Paypal votre sol en vie c'est de
vous lâcher complètement étudiant j'ai
assisté à des soirées à centralesupélec
et à l'École polytechnique j'ose même
pas vous raconter dans quel état on a
fini des événements gigantesques avec
les meilleurs DJ et musiciens du monde
le tout autour d'une quarantaine de
stands et d'alcool et des comportements
qui parfois dérivent une situation
exacerbée aux États-Unis ou les élèves
vivent en autarcie sur les campus si en
France 20% des élèves du supérieur
montrent des signes de faiblesse
psychologiques aux États-Unis le même
nombre ont sérieusement envisagé le
suicide la majorité des grandes
universités proposent des salles
d'études et des cafétéria 24 heures sur
24 ça encourage à bosser sans s'arrêter
certains étudiants oublieraient même de
se laver pour gagner du temps entre 70
et 96% des étudiants américains manquent
de sommeil 6,38 heures par nuit et ça
peut vous faire vriller ça pousse
certains à des solutions radicales
l'usage de drogue notamment avec des
dérives dans cet ami comme
général parfois les profonds abusent
c'est le cas dans les écoles d'art ou
d’architecture où ils sont souvent
considérés comme des mentors voire des
modèles ils sont très proches de leurs
élèves sa facilite beaucoup les
débordements autant psychologiques que
physiques le Sénat avait même publié un
rapport montrant le même phénomène entre
les doctorants et leur maître de thèse
j'en connais qui ont vécu trois ans ces
relations toxiques et qui ne s'en sont
jamais remis alors pourquoi y aller si
c'est horrible en France des études ont
même montré que l'impact sur votre
salaire en sortie d'études et
négligeable si vous avez le bon profil
vous pouvez aller ou bon vous semble pas
la peine de vous faire du mal mais pour
certaines catégories ça aide à gagner en
légitimité et ça crée des relations pour
les femmes la différence de salaire
atteint 14% d'autant plus triste quand
on sait qu'elles sont sous représentées
en France il y a plus de femmes que
d'hommes dans l'enseignement supérieur
mais leur nombre s'effondre dès la
classe prépa on les retrouve surtout en
sciences humaines l'être et médecine
mais elles sont absentes des formations
scientifiques et plus sélectives c'est
aussi ça le drame des grandes écoles ce
qui en profite le plus galère à y
accéder c'est pour ça que l'ENA a été
fermée en 2021 dans les années raconte
seule la moitié des élèves était fils et
fille de cadres 70% dans les années 2000
durant la dernière promotion un seul
élève était fils d'ouvriers si on
regarde les 10% d'école les plus
sélectives 70% de leurs élèves sont
issus de catégories
socio-professionnelles très favorisées
mixité sociale parfaite et sûrement un
vœu pieux mais c'est là la garantie
d'avoir des élites qui se renouvellent
et qui restent créative tout en
exacerbant pas des sentiments
d'injustice pouvant rompre l'ordre
social où devront aller vous enfants
pour réussir leur vie vous avez
peut-être entendu parler de leur stade
gymnasium situé au Danemark c'est
l'équivalent d'une classe prépa sa
spécialité il n'y a pas de salle de
classe à la place des espaces d'études
dans lesquels les professeurs sont
encouragés à expérimenter avec des
méthodes d'enseignement alternative on
se concentre sur la résolution de
problèmes on pose une colle aux élèves
et ils doivent trouver la réponse par
eux-mêmes pas besoin de prendre des
notes tout est numérisé vous travaillez
ou vous voulez l'enseignant n'est là que
pour vous aider sur la méthodologie aux
USA vous avez par exemple l'école quest
to learn qui fonctionne sur un principe
similaire pourquoi ça nous intéresse
vous avez peut-être entendu quelques
années ce chiffre 85% des métiers qui
existeront en 2030 n'ont pas encore été
inventées ils ont peut-être un peu
exagéré mais l'idée est là intelligence
artificielle robotique réalité virtuelle
un jour ils vont révolutionner notre
quotidien et faudra faire avec ce
jour-là ce seront les plus versatiles
qui vont en profiter c'est pour ça que
la tendance est d'apprendre à apprendre
des études moins structurées afin de
pouvoir se réorienter rapidement et
sauter sur toutes les occasions on parle
dans saigner des soft skills des
compétences passent partout le travail
d'équipe la communication à l'oral la
pensée critique ou la résolution
problème comme ça si jamais ce que vous
avez passé 5 ans à étudier devient
obsolètes vous pouvez toujours rebondir
l'autre grand défi bien sûr c'est
l'informatique avec la pandémie on a
réalisé que c'était possible d'enseigner
à distance et à grande échelle cela
permet d'entrevoir une simplification de
l'accès à une éducation d'élite plus
forcément besoin de traverser l'océan
Atlantique pour apprendre auprès des
meilleurs et aujourd'hui vous pouvez
assister à des master class Harvard pour
un peu plus de
1500$. aux idées des cours en open
source du MIT imp il y a quelques années
dans le futur peut-être que les
formations que vous suivez en ligne
auront plus de valeur que vos cours en
présentiel évidemment c'est un peu plus
compliqué que ça les cours en ligne
peuvent s'avérer compliquer le futur
combinera sûrement les deux alors quoi
les grandes universités disparaitront
sûrement pas et c'est pas ça qu'on leur
souhaite avec des établissements qui
produisent une éducation de qualité tout
en s'épanouissant c'est indispensable si
vous pouvez en profiter les grandes
universités ont des tas d'avantages ce
sont des lieux avec des conditions
optimales pour s'épanouir et apprendre
vous allez y rencontrer des gens
d'horizon divers discuter avec des
pointures dans leur domaine former un
réseau de contact humain et
professionnel qui facilitera votre
arrivée dans le monde du travail si on
pointe les défauts ce n'est pas pour
détruire mais améliorer en France si on
veut réussir la transition va falloir
faire mieux on a par exemple un gros
problème avec nos doctorants qui sont
bien moins valorisés que dans le reste
du monde leur seule option étant de
devenir enseignant chercheur ce n'est
pas forcément leur vocation et même là
avoir une place est difficile résultat
leur nombre diminue près de 80000 il y a
10 ans 10 000 de moins aujourd'hui alors
les USA ils sont en constante
augmentation pour envisager le futur on
a besoin de personnes qualifiées prêtes
à transmettre le savoir il faut prendre
soin de nos professeurs aujourd'hui ils
sont 100 000 de moins qu'en 2000 le
nombre d'élèves lui n'a pas bougé dans
une robe vieillissante sans grande
ressources naturelles une population
éduquée et la dernière richesse qu'il
nous reste alors ne la gâchons pas et
investissons dans l'avenir
[Musique]